okay so this video is gonna be about
coral bleaching so let's go ahead and
get started well you know first we need
to understand what coral are coral are
tiny invertebrate animals in the same
family as jellyfish and anemones they
have a very soft body which we simply
call a polyp and many times the polyp is
hidden inside of the shell that they
produce but there's a soft body called a
polyp if we look at this picture right
here we can see the polyp exposed and
here's about a dozen or so polyps
individual polyps of coral and if we
zoom in a little closer we see four or
five individual polyps here in this
picture here so these are corals tiny
and vertebrate animals so I mentioned a
moment ago that coral have a shell to
them a calcium based exoskeleton calcium
carbonate and they secrete this
protective shell and as a way to better
defend themselves against their
predators and as time goes by reefs
coral reefs begin to form as polyps grow
and die and their shells are left behind
and new polyps grow and die and their
shells are left behind and new polyps
grow and die and their shells are left
behind and over time over time reefs
develop into the coral reefs that were
typically used to seeing like we see in
these pictures right here
coral reefs play an important role in
the ecosystem of oceans you know they
occupy a very small percentage of the
area of the earth in yet they are home
to about 25% of all ocean life simply
because coral contain photosynthetic
elements to them where they're able to
do photosynthesis which is the basis of
ocean food chains
so why are they so colorful well I just
mention that coral contain a
photosynthetic element let me explain
what I mean by that
coral live in a mutualistic relationship
with an algae called Zhu anthalie Zhu
anthalie algae if we kind of zoom in to
one of the tentacles here of the coral
we see that there are actual living LG
that will occupy the tissue of the coral
it's what gives the coral their color
without the algae the the coral would be
a white or a transparent white colorless
organism and so as I just said the Zhu
anthalie algae provide the color of the
corals whether it's kind of more yellow
or kind of the violet color we see here
or maybe some of the oranges that we see
that the color of coral comes from the
algae that are living in the tissue of
the coral and so again a great example
of a mutualistic relationship and if
you're familiar with mutualism it's a
symbiotic relationship where both
individuals both organisms benefit by
living off of one another the coral
provides a home for the zoo anthalie
algae and the zoo anthalie algae because
it's an algae it's photosynthetic takes
in sunlight water and carbon dioxide and
produces glucose and so the glucose from
the zoo anthalie algae is the primary
source of food for the coral to survive
off of you know another common example
of mutualism is between a bumblebee and
a flower you know a bumblebee provides a
service of pollinating a flower and the
flower provides nectar or food for the
bumblebee they both benefit you know a
fun example of mutualism right is an
example right here between a bird called
the the Egyptian plover and a crocodile
the bird eats parasites out of the mouth
of the crocodile and the crocodile
obtains a cleaning they both been
so what is coral bleaching that's the
topic of this video well when stressed
the zoo anthalie algae are actually
expelled from the coral the coral lose
their color now it's a lot more
important a lot more serious than just
the coral lose their pretty color color
there's a lot more to it than that
what makes coral bleaching so important
is that the corals are more susceptible
to disease you imagine they just lost
the zoo anthalie algae which is their
primary source of food and so now of
course the more susceptible to disease
they're less likely to survive simply
because number one they lost one of
their main sources of food the glucose
created by the zillionth alais algae so
now they're more susceptible to disease
so what are some of the human causes of
coral bleaching what's causing the
stress of the coral where they expel the
algae well water pollution is one of the
leading causes in the picture here we
see an example of runoff where we have a
storm drain bringing pollutants into the
ocean ecosystem here in this picture we
see an oil tanker that has released oil
and there's an oil spill well so all of
this of course would add to the
pollution levels which would stress the
stress the coral causing the release of
the zoo anthalie algae but probably one
of the more striking causes of coral
bleaching is through climate change and
global warming through the use of coal
oil natural gas burning these fossil
fuels for industry burning these fossil
fuels for automobiles
you know releases a lot of pollutants
into the air and so when we look at this
graph right here we see the blue line
representing the amount of carbon
dioxide just going up and up and up and
up and up and up well now we also look
at the red line the red line shows the
average global temperature going up and
up and up and up and up and so the
increased temperature increases
the temperature of the ocean water as
well and that's one of the biggest
causes of coral bleaching is the warmer
ocean temperatures are causing the the
the corals to release their zoo and
delay algae and so what are some of the
impacts of coral bleaching
well ocean ecosystems are of course
becoming devastated as a result of this
we think of a simple food chain right
here the coral is consumed by the fish
the fish is consumed by the squid the
squid is consumed by the shark you
imagine what impact would we have if the
coral were suddenly removed from this
ecosystem here the producer the bottom
of the food chain the photosynthetic
producers if they were to be removed
slowly by surely as we move up and up
and up the food chain other organisms
would start to diminish if not be wiped
out completely
well corals absorb carbon dioxide keep
in mind there they contain
photosynthetic algae in that when they
take in carbon dioxide they use that
carbon dioxide to help build their
skeletons and so here we have six carbon
dioxide molecules and one by one the
carbon dioxide has been absorbed because
of the algae that do photosynthesis so
we know that the protection of corals is
one way to combat and fight climate
change and yet we're kind of doing the
opposite where our actions are leading
to their destruction so it's just a way
to another way to connect corals to
climate change coral reefs
reefs actually help to protect
shorelines from the impact of waves they
kind of act like a natural breakwater to
kind of dampen the impact the repeated
impact of waves protecting shorelines
and maybe property that could be built
along the shoreline and let's not forget
that many people visit reefs and
tropical areas you know for tourists
tourism for terrorist purposes and so to
slowly see the destruction of
Reef's over time we'll start to see
again less and less tourism so what are
some ways to lessen the effects of coral
bleaching you really it comes down to
reducing our carbon footprint you know
here's a list of ways that we can do
that around the house such as recycling
such as starting a carpool with friends
and family going for walks when we might
be tempted to drive a short distance you
know drying our clothes on a clothesline
you know going for bike rides instead of
again maybe driving a shorter distance
you know using compact fluorescent light
bulbs is a great way to save energy
around the house having our automobile
properly serviced makes it run more fuel
efficiently and for those who maybe can
afford to explore the option of more
fuel-efficient greener automobiles and
finally to plant some trees you know as
I wrap up this video here I want to have
you if you're interested click this
button here for more ways to reduce our
carbon footprint so go ahead and put
your comments in the box below and I
hope you found this video to be helpful
thanks for watching